well in the moral sphere I think they
would be based upon criteria such as
suffering instead of absolutist criteria
like all killing of humans is wrong for
example including killing of early human
embryos we would instead say well who's
suffering what I bought at what point in
the balance does the sufferings switch
over to the other to the other side when
there's a choice if we got rid of
absolutist moral criteria we might stop
saying human life is absolutely sacred
and you can't put a monetary value on it
and you actually do put a monetary value
on it all the time because you know
whenever you make a decision like shall
we have another kidney machine or shall
we what to what safety standards should
be billed airliners one if one could
always make airliners a little bit safer
but it would cost a lot more money and
so we do already take decisions about
that military aircraft are built to a
less risk-averse standard than civilian
aircraft we already do make judgments of
this kind so that would be the moral of
that kind of thing would change in the
moral sphere in the scientific sphere
we'd be able to get on with our science
as science and not have to worry about
whether we're giving offence to people
who get their beliefs from holy books
rather than from evidence which we at
present have to worry about in the field
of Education we could go in for science
education free to actually teach
children the best science we know teach
children to use the scientific method of
thinking and once again not have to pay
lip service to or respect the dopey
beliefs of their parents who try to
interfere with their scientific
education
you